but for people not familiar with who
steve bannon is a hugely influential
figure in the
white house some time ago and continues
to exert a lot of influence outside of
mainstream politics
a founding father of the alt-right
exactly yeah you still see him
he still has a very prominent public
profile
calling on tv and so on chief analyst on
various
political channels over here he was
hugely influential
in terms of the trump administration
particularly in the early days he was
chief
strategist for donald trump his
right-hand man
dubbed by time magazine the second most
powerful man
in the world he had huge influence
inside the white house
and his philosophy his politics
are recognized as having driven the camp
to trump
campaign and driven donald trump across
the the finishing line in 2016.
he was a jettison from the white house
staff in august 2017
interestingly these charges that he now
faces they date back to
2018 so post his departure from
the white house but what's happened
today is that this morning bannon
was one of four individuals who were
arrested in connection with this scheme
it was called we build the wall an
online
fundraising scheme it raised 25 million
pounds it was supposedly non-profit but
these individuals were using the cash to
line their own pockets
steve bannon himself had said or is
accused of having taken a million
and having spent hundreds of thousands
of pounds on personal
expenses the inspector the police
inspector in charge
of this operation uh saying in a press
release today these individuals
had no regard for the law or for truth
steve bannon and the others are expected
to make their first appearances in court
a bit later today baron himself in new
york and as you say our
understanding is that he will plead not
guilty